hey everyone this is sarah with
registered nurse RN comm and today i
want to show you how to give an
injection in the door so gluteal muscle
this is another type of IM injection in
my previous videos i showed you how to
give an injection in the deltoid and the
ventricle so this one we're going to do
the door so cool first what you want to
do is you want to explain the procedure
to the patient do hand hygiene and
gather your supplies and here we have
miss smith we have her in the prone
position which is on her belly because
this is the position you want to give
this your medications in whenever you're
giving an injection in the door so
gluteal muscle so what we do the key to
giving these injections is finding your
landmarks you'll want to find the great
trochanter and then you'll want to find
the top of the iliac the prominence of
the iliac crest which is about in this
region right here once you find your
great trochanter and the prominence of
the iliac crest you want to draw an
imaginary line okay after you have your
imaginary line drawn you're going to
just place your finger above it where
your line would be and you're going to
go above that line the reason you want
to go above that line is because in this
region right here beside the SAP sciatic
nerve runs so you do not want to hit
that
so we have our landmarks and we have
where we want to go we're going to get
our alcohol prep and we're going to
clean the site and a nice circular
motion for about three to five seconds
killing any germs and you're going to
get your injection ready you're going to
go in at a 90 degree angle and you're
going to aspirate of course as with all
i''m injections make sure you don't have
any blood just pull back a little bit
and we have no blood and so we're going
to inject keep it there just for a
second texture all that medicine gets in
you're going to pull out engage your
safety
put a galls over the area because it
might be bleeding or a band-aid and then
you're done so that is how you give an
injection in the
dorsa gluteal muscle if you liked this
video please share it with your friends
um if you have any questions or anything
come to our website registered nurse RN
calm and be sure to visit the forum and
thank you so much for watching